ils vivent parfois au bord des routes
nationales pas forcément moins de paris
mais toujours loin de ceux qui les
dirigent leur vie ressemble assez peu à
ce qu'on voit à la télé ils ont le
sentiment d'être des français de seconde
zone comme s'ils étaient invisibles ces
français ne veulent plus tard ils ont
des choses à dire la france oubliée
c'est une rencontre avec ces citoyens
qui ne se résignent pas à la fatalité
la france humiliée s'est montré ce qu'on
ne voit jamais
je me rends maintenant à compiègne dans
l'oise pour rencontrer nicolas et sandra
vendeurs et créateur de mobilier
[Musique]
bonjour chat dernier voit sa caverne
d'ali baba
un petit peu mais vous avez vous
présenter donc je m'appelle nicolas
jallot combien et la voilà et l'autre
vous avez quel âge 40 ans 37 éoliennes
on a créé du magasin ya quatre ans on va
vous allez nous montrer un petit peu
allez on va faire le tour de la boutique
voilà alors le ont présenté un petit peu
ce qu'on fait donc on a deux activités
pour ainsi dire on a la partie vintage
ou là on cherche vraiment au shin des
pièces donc on aime bien tout ce qui est
tout ce qui est philippe heures tout ce
qui est juif box pour ce qui est un jeu
d'arcade et après on à l'autre partie
qui est vraiment la partie création
c'est un atelier ça m'a dit c'est ouais
c'est au shin des petites pièces à
droite à gauche on met dans un univers
revalorise voilà et qu'on met dans un
univers dans un univers un petit peu
sympa quoi donc un petit peu tout ça
part un peu dans tous les sens et
c'était quelque chose qui arrive est un
petit peu dans la douleur tout ça parce
que moi j'avais une carrosserie qui a
brûlé donc voilà je rentrerai dans le
détail mais bon voilà c'était c'était 10
ans de 10 ans de travail qui est parti
en fumée malheureusement donc on est
reparti d'une feuille blanche et son
aura cet incident fait bateau et au
souci en fait fracture au niveau de la
colonne vertébrale enfin deux des
vertèbres donc une aptitude pour la
création et j'ai toujours aimé la déco
do do usine à gaz est né on sent bon
plus nous on est une famille recomposée
pour la petite histoire donc c'est vrai
que cette société là c'est notre bébé
mais voilà ces deux bébés donc
effectivement on a mis
l'énergie du désespoir et puis les
derniers sous qui nous restait donc vous
lancer quelque chose qui vous plaît qui
fonctionne qui démarque des soldes après
on m'a d'abord confinement exactement
donc et donc vous avez créé je vois là
ouais c'est plate forme bi tah fait donc
en fait nous on est beaucoup sur les
réseaux sociaux ça fait partie de ça
fait partie vraiment des de notre
manière de fonctionner nous faire
connaître on travaille beaucoup avec les
réseaux sociaux et donc du coup on s'est
dit on ne doit pas être les seuls à être
dans cette situation là forcément je
vais créer une petite page facebook qui
s'appelle entrepreneurs en sursis et on
s'est dit bon bah on va se refiler des
infos on va être dix quinze vingt
personnes du coin où on se connaît on se
refile les infos et il s'est avéré que
ça a été au delà de nos espérances
puisque à l'heure où je vous parle on
est presque 1800 sur la page
tous les petits un petit peu les petits
oublié où on nous fait débat s'annonce
est-ce que vous dans les reports de
charges etc
est-ce que c'est aussi simple que ça
est-ce que c'est aussi là-bas c'est pas
simple c'est pas simple parce que
aujourd'hui on nous on nous parle de on
nous parle d' aide mais aujourd'hui
entre ce qu'on nous annonce et faire les
dossiers demandés les heures sandra à
passer pour pour arriver à voir que ce
soit des décalages de charge des
dossiers de subventions d ça prend un
temps de dingue
on n'est pas une grosse structure où on
va avoir un responsable juridique qui va
s'occuper que ça nous on est dans notre
boulot maintenant en très compliqué
c'est compliqué qu'il faut rentrer dans
les cases
moi c'est ce que j'ai expliqué aux
premiers confinement on nous avait dit
vous allez toucher 1500 euros dead c'est
très bien ok faut savoir qu'une
structure comme nous on a besoin de haut
niveau trésorerie juste pour le
fonctionnement les charges 1500 euros on
est loin du coup nous avant de prendre
un salaire ici c'est 7000 euros
bah oui c'est celle hormis leurs autres
pôles et chez agc
aujourd'hui on nous avait proposé la
fausse bonne idée mais fera excusez moi
mais ont proposé un crédit
on nous dit vous allez le pge vous allez
faire un crédit au nom de faire un
crédit pour payer des chalets comme les
reports de charges ça c'est pas annuler
ces sons été dur pour un autre les
loyers qui ont nous on a eu la chance
d'avoir notre propriétaire qui nous l'a
décalé mais ça fait pas cadeau non plus
on va pas dire qu'il ya pas d il y en a
je vais te donner un exemple mais on
peut avoir deux mille euros mais ça va
nous prendre quatre jours et de
déplacements pour avoir ces sous la dent
réfléchi à deux fois car la belle
travailler à peut-être travailler parce
que nous on est là pour moi c'est enfin
sentir un meuble combat vendée on aura
beaucoup plus de fierté que d'avoir que
d'avoir des aides parce que nous on
n'est pas des chasseurs de primes
on va travailler la sueur sur les
cadeaux de noël
donc on va se mettre à la partie
chaudronnerie une petite chaudronnerie
donc où je prenne m'occupe de tout la
soudure
vous comprenez quand même ce confinement
on a quand même eu un sentiment on va
pas se mentir d'art justice concernant
cette deuxième ce deuxième confinement
quand on est parent aujourd'hui quand on
voit des grosses enseignes je vais pas
leur faire de publicité mais des grosses
enseignes qui ont le droit d'ouvrir qui
sont à 500 mètres de chez nous qui
vendent des produits similaires aux
nôtres
eux ils peuvent ouvrir et nous doit
fermer les portes
un certain nombre de personnes par mètre
carré et basta nous même si on était
limité à trois personnes en même temps
dans la boutique on respecterait et on a
toujours respecté les règles qu'on nous
a imposé que ce soit le masque les le
gel on a toujours respecté et la
distanciation n'a les affiches on a tout
ce qu'il faut nous on veut juste vivre
de notre métier c'est tout après donc on
n'arrive pas à comprendre
vous pouvez tenir encore combien de
temps
sincèrement c'est sans aide on passera
pas la fin d'année si on n'a pas des
delà là tout de suite maintenant c'est
clair et net
on a bouffé tout la trésorerie dont
quatre ans d'économies depuis la
création de la société avec le pro de la
première vague bras trésorerie on en a
plus d écembre sylla ont continué qui a
pas dead on va commencer à avoir des
difficultés pour pouvoir tout régler ça
c'est en sachant que d'espacés c'est un
de nos gros mois prochain
une c'est notre gros ça vous avez vu une
manifestation de solidarité un peu dans
nos clients sont les premiers à passer
ceux qui aiment notre univers qui sont
des clients qui nous suivent sont les
premiers mais des fois nous envoyer des
messages avec des bons on compte sur
vous comment on peut vous aider
on a des soutiens
aussi deux confrères on essaye de céder
entre confrères près le reste qu à vous
dire ça c'est clair ça c'est clair
finalement tous ces coups durs ça vous à
rapprocher tous les deux oui c'est aussi
dans la difficulté quand on voit le
couple est solide et puis si les
affaires aussi son solide parce que ça
va être aussi un révélateur cette
période là toutes les
toutes les sociétés voilà c'est toute la
société qui est qu'ils sont vraiment
trop bancal tiennent le coup ça veut
dire qu'elles sont pas si mon cal que ça
ça ça peut-être un petit message aussi à
passer aux banques est là devant vous
avez vu si on arrive à passer cette
période là avec toutes les difficultés
qu'on a ça veut dire qu'on sait se
retrousser les manches
et si demain on a un projet pour faire
autre chose de plus gros regardez
peut-être pas trop le bilan mais
regardez plus aussi la personnalité des
gens ouais on va la faire de voir la
photo fait sympa rendre à pau ouais
voilà tu grandis drapeau de la liberté
dans l'oeuf le club vois la magnifique
[Musique]